hey guys it's justine and today is
another day which means
we have another fun unboxing for you
today we're gonna be showcasing this
laptop by msi so a huge thank you to msi
for sponsoring this video
and i already just i'm just gonna tell
you spoiler
this laptop is pink shall we open it
yes
oh oh there's a surprise in here
a little pink laptop case
[Music]
oh it's pretty look there's nothing
wrong with having a pretty laptop you
can have a laptop be pretty and powerful
okay oh a little handle oh
another little handle
oh this is a surprise to me there's even
a wireless mouse that it comes with
what the heck and
did somebody say that they wanted
an msi dragon keychain we've got our
power adapter
you guys come on you should have made it
paint
look at that a nice little usb ethernet
adapter
for all of your ethernetting needs
let's check this mouse out portable
quiet and precise
oh yeah check this out
look at you oh
ah that's funny i um
i have just threw them
durability test check
thank you tyler
i never know what might just hit me in
the face you really
you really don't they're calling this
color rose pink
and it's freaking beautiful now it's
time to take a peek at this laptop
baby look i don't want to be like
stereotypical or anything but
i'm a sucker for pink
i'm so excited to see this i need to
take a moment okay moment over
oh look we're here to help little msi
dragon is just so
cute look at you
you're all covered up in like a little
blanket
oh shoot shoot
look at this oh wow freaking
wee
so let's open this up and there's a
really exciting surprise
freaking folds all the way
back let's turn this thing on and test
it out
so this rose pink version is a limited
edition one but they also have a pure
white
carbon gray and urban silver in the
prestige series
this is the 14 inch model there's also a
15 inch available as well
and this is powered by the intel evo
platform let's take a look and see what
ports we have
over here we've got a micro sd card slot
headphone jack
and also a usb 3. and on the other side
we have two
thunderbolt 4 ports and it charges right
there
via usbc this is also very light like
i'm surprised how light this is
i'm obsessed with this color it is
really
really pretty and if this color isn't
your favorite
it's okay they have others you know pink
is not for everyone but it is for me
i love that the mouse matches and i also
love that this is something that is
obviously geared towards portability but
also doesn't lack in performance
and hello
matching little case
like if i was in college right now i
would be this would be me
they'd see me rolling they'd be hating
i'm ready to go to school although if i
was going to school right now i
basically would be walking downstairs
probably into my kitchen because we
don't go anywhere
anymore still still still
how what's really great about the intel
evo platform is intel is working
directly with laptop manufacturers
to optimize not only the software but
all of the performance so it's kind of
great to be able to go in and actually
be able to optimize all of these things
there's even an application optimizer so
there's a high performance option
so this configuration boosts the highest
possible performance for heavy tasks
like gaming and there's also a balanced
this is a cozy
i love that it says it's cozy and best
system setting that msi recommends then
there's a silent mode
and this is kind of neat because this
will keep your system noise level really
low
if you're doing like a zoom call or
something like that this will be
optimized for that
and then over here look at this super
battery the best battery life and lowest
possible power consumption
for basic needs i'm basic
and i need things there is also a
built-in webcam there's a little webcam
button here too that will allow you to
turn
the webcam access on or off
i just love privacy controls
i wonder if jenna would want to do an
msi laptop to msi laptop
conference call
[Music]
me
hello
hi okay there we go are you on your msi
laptop
i am are you um yes so mine's rose gold
which color is yours i'm asking her like
i didn't just watch her video
i have the light i know i i watched your
video so that was just
i know i already know what color you
have but your color looks really cool
but this pink is beautiful did you get a
mouse with yours
no oh i did
what yeah i think they have different
options because i also saw that you got
like that little
adapter as well like the dongle yeah i
did
so nice i got one of those but mine had
an ethernet
oh look at that so there's the lan port
and then it has the micro
and the regular sd and then the two uh
usb
type a cool the one thing that i really
liked is so i can turn my
camera off with just the press of a
button bye
do you see me no
do you see me now
yeah okay well i'm gonna go this was a
really great chat i had a lot of fun i
hope that you also had as much fun as i
did
all right we'll probably see you soon
cool bye bye
oh so i said the past few days of this
laptop and i've done everything from
email to conference calls i played some
video games and then i just sort of did
all of my everyday normal tasks that i
do
every single day that's why they're
everyday normal tasks i'm always doing a
lot of email i'm taking a ton of notes
for future videos or various projects so
i'm constantly doing that and having to
do revisions for scripts i do love
how light this is because there are a
lot of times that i'm working from the
couch or i'm actually just sitting on
the floor or i'm working from a
different couch or a different chair the
thing about me that i've been noticing
is when i am working from home i don't
last very long in one
specific location so being able to have
a laptop that is light and portable
is really important something that i
thought was kind of unique about this
laptop is there is more of an angle
on the keyboard and for me it seemed
like it was actually making a difference
i like that this has two different
privacy options for the microphone and
the camera so on f5 and f8
this gives you the option with one press
to turn the microphone or
the camera off or on i kind of like this
for conference calls because there's so
many times
where it's just easier to just be able
to hit
one single key then go in and unmute
yourself every single time in the actual
interface so this is kind of neat
i like the keyboard it has a really nice
key travel type on it
it's just like cozy like a comfy little
key press
i like that the fingerprint sensor is
kind of built into the trackpad i like
the size of the trackpad it kind of
makes it feel like it's larger than it
is and even the keys
sometimes on smaller laptops like this
the keys are a little bit smaller but
this is like a full-size keyboard
they really did do a great job on this
device this limited edition pink rose is
the perfect gift for valentine's day
having that intel evo platform brings
the combination of performance
responsiveness and battery life with the
iris xe graphics you're getting not only
a stylish laptop but that performance
and lightweight portability all thanks
to intel evo thank you guys so much for
watching i had so much fun checking out
this laptop and i still
just can't get over this incredible
color like it's so beautiful
again a huge thank you to msi for
sponsoring this video i'll put a link in
the description where you can find out
all of the information about this laptop
and more and i will see all of you guys
in my next video
bye
[Music]
you